realllly die what's the purpose of life
brother and he gonna show you all the
deets
this is the unique greeting the greeting
of the angels the greetings of the
messengers and we're greeting you with
that greeting here today peace be unto
you and today we have a special guest
sheikh abdul rahim green who's come back
here on the Deen show he's with us again
he shared his story he went from
Christianity to Buddhism to Islam
acquiring peace by submitting his will
to the owner of peace not to a man to a
woman but to create a man and woman to
one God and he's here with us again to
talk some more so you don't want to go
[Music]
[Music]
there's only one bed and Jesus was his
messenger know why I did that maybe it
maybe it's just to break the ice I'm
here with the cool sheikh sheikh abdul
rahim green on the Deen show this is the
green show today
can I take nobody yes how are you I like
I like being cool if I am cool but I
like being cool Islam is cool
and it's cool to be a Muslim is cool to
acquire peace by submitting to the one
guy doing all the good that he's told us
to do and people can go back to the Deen
show calm there's your special section
there people can see the story and how
you came to Islam now you've grown all
praises to God Almighty Allah that
you're out there educating the not-yet
Muslims and the Muslims about Islam
that's right yeah this is amazing well
that the you know it's the least you can
do you know I think if you really love
something you can't help but share that
thing with people it's just inevitable
it's you know it's a psychological
condition if you really love something
and you that thing benefits you you want
everyone else to benefit from it as well
so how can you stop yourself sharing the
beautiful message of Islam once you've
tasted it and experienced it and you
know how sweet it is and how completely
it fulfills the life of an individual
you feel compelled to want to share that
beautiful experience with everyone else
sharing is caring and we care about the
people that's why we want to share it's
not absolutely absolutely now the thing
is that you said it you said if I had
ever read a book like never read a book
that was from God this was it that was
from God Almighty it was this Quran you
shuffled around you went around and you
experienced all these different
religions and then you finally came to
the truth because Islam provided the
proof that it wasn't man-made but it was
divinely sent from the one God and you
didn't want to worship a man got you
also just kind of bringing people up to
speed these are some of the things we
talked about I remember like it was
yesterday
you said a penny dropped it was like a
penny drop when the man said what well
when he said to me do you believe that
Jesus is God and I said yes and he said
do you believe that Jesus died on the
cross
I said yes so he said well God died and
that was it was just like I realized
that I realized that I didn't believe
that I I didn't believe that God could
die but no one had really spelled him
out for me no one had really said look
this is the logical rational end result
of your belief system I knew something
was wrong with it the whole time because
I always was questioning and felt
uncomfortable with it but it took
someone to really spell out look this
plus this equals this when he did it was
an epiphany you know like you say the
penny dropped and you came to the
realization that I don't want to worship
the creation I want to worship the
create or elaborate on when we say the
creped or some people just mix it all up
they say gods and you gods of me we're
all God's God could be a mess and it
gets confusing define when we say the
creator and the creation just worship
the crater what do we mean well I think
it's really beautifully summed up in a
very short but extremely powerful
al-almost form and let merely do one
amulet well a mere two laughs go for one
handed which is actually called sort of
a class which means the purity is the
purity of faith and it says Allahu Ahad
Allah who summit let me lead well I'm
here at what a miracle the hook of
one-eyed which means that say he is
Allah I had now the word I had means one
and alone it's not just one you know you
could give one or I could be one but one
and alone without any partners so the
the concept of Trinity is excluded in a
head so Allah is a head he is one and
alone and he
is a summit summit means that God is the
one upon whom everything depends
everything needs God whereas God doesn't
need anything so this idea that some
people have that maybe by worshipping
God you're making God stronger it's like
so maybe there's a competition between
the gods and like whichever God gets
more worshipers no Allah doesn't need
anyone to worship you don't need what
doesn't need anything he doesn't because
he he depends upon nothing whether we
worship Him or not
it doesn't make any difference to the
fact that Allah is the sovereign God is
the sovereign of the heavens on earth so
he needs nothing
he's totally self-sufficient whereas in
fact everything in the creation is
entirely and completely dependent upon a
god lamb ulid means he is not born no
one gave birth to Allah so he didn't
have a beginning
Allah is the everliving he has no
beginning well I'm glad and also he is
not the forget it means God does not you
know have children he doesn't have
daughters
he doesn't have son so this whole
concept of sons of god and daughters of
god
this is reducing the creator to being
like some created thing and and well um
you could look upon had and that already
seals it there's nothing that Allah the
Creator God is not like anything in the
creation now this is really the essence
of the monotheistic belief in Islam
about God leisa commit nahi shade there
is nothing that can and I think really
you find that a lot of religions
although they say we believe in God but
their concept of God they've reduced
Allah they reduced God to being almost
like some created thing in their minds
they don't really comprehend they
haven't really absorbs how great God is
and you find that in our call to prayer
when we start our ritual prayers what is
the thing that the words that we say
again and again
Allah Allah worker but actually means
Allah is greater you'd say well Allah is
greater
well Allah is greater than anything you
can imagine now you think about our
universe if you think about ours if you
think about our galaxy which is ten
thousand light-years across that means
if you travel from ten thousand years in
the speed of light you would that's how
long it would take to cross our universe
Wow
that and our galaxy is one of millions
in the universe the universe is what
billions of light years across
and this universe the Prophet said is
like a ring in a desert
compared to the [ __ ] which means the
pedestal of the chair and the courtesy
is like a ring in the desert can you
just imagine a ring thrown in the desert
it's like it compared to the throne of
God
so how great is God so this you know
when you really try and imagine how
insignificant this creation is compared
to the greatest creation of a lot of the
throne then how great is all well and so
this idea that people have how they've
reduced Allah to being some man that
breathes and eats and goes to the
Twitter and they think that God is like
some created thing with the weaknesses
of a created thing then they have not
really understood how majestic and holy
and great the Creator is before we go to
break did any of the prophets ever teach
or preach that God was a man who stone
never how could they every messenger
came and taught what I am talking about
now the God that nothing is like I'm not
and you can see it in the Bible you can
see it you know even the remains of the
Bible you know
there is nothing that can be compared to
God those statements are there in the
text so this is the teachers of all of
the messages real quick real quick 30
seconds you mentions even some verses I
mean was it Hosea that it says God is
not a man yes for I am God not men so
there you go how can about me man be God
you know the Bible itself confirms those
teachings the first commandment thou
shalt love the Lord your God and thou
shalt not the second commandment thou
shalt not make any graven images of
anything in the heavens or the earth or
in the sea and you shall not bow down
and you should not worship them I mean
that's the essence you can't make an
image of God because God has no image
like anything and this is what we're
talking about
I know it's making sense and it's making
even more sense if you're sincere and
you have an open heart open mind right
back with more on the D show when
outside everything looks good you see
the hundred thousand dollar cars you see
a lot of diamonds you see a lot of
females and they think that this is you
know this is a life this is this is like
no paradise right here or
with a job to go into someone's heart to
change the heart your job is to topi
what the truthers and the alley of it is
while we're sitting here while I'm
sitting here constantly paying for the
disease the kill was free back here on
the Dean Shaw with shaykh abdul rahim
green on the green show today this is
the green show ladies and gentlemen on
the Dean show I'm so excited that you're
back with us well it's great to be back
ideas usual thank you thank you for
finding the time and inshallah we'll get
to be together some more over the years
if God Almighty gives us life and then
hopefully we do enough good deeds we
worship the One God and we do the good
that he's told us to do and then you'll
have mercy on us
we'll have grace on us and give us
paradise that's the objective as we go
that's what we want to get exactly so
tell us now there's the quote this was
just an introduction now the question is
because many people this is in their
nature this is something that is logical
rational just worship the One God and do
the good that he wants you to do now
someone writes in a question says you
know what yeah that makes sense but how
could God who's so merciful and loving
how can he send a good person to the
Hellfire and I think that somebody even
asked you this question are many times
before and how do you answer this so we
can clear out some of the confusion and
then we can clear the path for them to
totally submit to the one God talk to us
well I think you know first of all we
- we have to have a working definition
of good and this is a really big a very
profound topic because if you merely
define good as whatever is acceptable in
your society then you could argue that
well in Nazi Germany the good people of
Nazi Germany were the ones who killed
the most Jews is that a working
definition of good I think most people
today would agree that there are some
things that are absolutely evil and they
you know they always will be and they
always have been evil and you know
genocide wiping out populations of human
beings is something we pretty much agree
upon is evil but you know imagine
conceptually that the whole world was
taken over by Nazis and we'd all been
converted by a Nazi propaganda to
believe that we should kill Jews and we
all think that the guy who kills the
most users is a good guy this is evil as
well but this is the point you see when
a person says how can good people go to
hell my first question is who defines
what's good do you define what's good to
society define what's good from our
position we would say that the only one
who has the right to define what is good
is God in fact the very essence of what
makes something good or evil is the fact
that this notion of good and evil itself
is anchored in a transcendental concept
something meaning it's something beyond
ourselves right and so that is very very
important the concept of good and evil
so the first thing is well the first
thing I talk about is well who defines
god right it can't just be a sorry who
defines good a good can't we just be
defined by society or by you or me so
when a person said you know why do good
people go to hell I'd say well who said
that's a good person who decides what's
good who decided what what
a person good the other way to think
about it is that truly good people don't
go to hell
and truly good people as far as God has
defined it as far as the Creator has
defined it good has a foundation and
that foundation starts with that
person's relationship and recognition
and obedience and submission to God
sometimes people find this a hard
concept to get their heads around so
what I what I what I try to do is
explain this concept in you know in a
way that's a little bit familiar to us
and of course in no way do I want to
compare God to any created thing I'm
just trying to give the concept some you
know some framework for which we can
understand it sort of I want you to
imagine right Eddie you're you know
you're you're sort of journalists right
and you know the Dean show you have the
Dean show you decide one day you hear
about this guy who he's a really good
guy
he gives lots of charity he's kind to
kids you know he's good-looking like me
you know and like you you know although
I don't know whatever right whatever you
think you know this guy is a great guy
yeah but this guy keeps on saying bad
things about his parents doctor my my
parents my parent you know he just says
a bad thing so you being a journalist
you say I want to find out who are these
parents they must be awful people
right so you track them down and you
interview them then you find out that
they're the sweetest nicest kindest
people they gave everything to their son
everything everything to make their to
educate him they lived in poverty so
that he could you know whatever whatever
you think but they gave everything they
never did anything bad to him right now
what do you think of this guy
he's a creep now yeah and you know what
the fact is that all the good that he
did just looks like nothing started go
out the window
yeah because you'd say I can't ever
think of a person who would treat his
parents like that as being good it
doesn't matter what he does for the hold
of humanity but if you can't treat his
parents properly how can we look at him
as good as it because there are some
things that are so bad it outweighs all
the good that you do and that's how we
should look at a person who denies God
who abuses God who considers something
in the creation to be equal with God
this is so insulting and so abusive and
sold denying the reality of God and in
reality God has more right to be loved
more right to be worshipped you're right
to be spent respected than even your own
parents
I mean God gave you your parents right
so this really emphasizes the point that
you can do something that is so bad that
it outweighs all the good you can do and
that is what shook or making partners or
making equals denying God denying God's
prophets denying his religion turning
away from God in the eyes of God it is
so bad that whatever you do outweighs
the the evil of making partners with God
of denying God outweighs whatever good
you can do right and so this is the
context in which we have to understand
this issue where people say oh how can a
good person go to hell well we'd say no
on a truly good person would never go to
hell but yes a person may seem to do
nice things and good things and help
other human beings and may be so
charitable of us on that but at the end
of the day if they have not recognized
God and obeyed God and committed
themselves to treating their
relationship with God in the right way
then the evil of that always all
and by doing God's will by doing what
the Creator wants you to do he tells you
to be the most merciful to see the
ability to be good to everyone
absolutely you see here's the point that
in Islam you give your rights to go you
see we will talk about rights human
rights animals rights you know Pro even
the trees rights right okay and that's
good it's good that everything has
rights and we should treat everything
but how about the right of God how about
the duty and the right and the
obligation that we owe to our Creator
they you know this is the most terrible
right to transgress but as you said when
you follow Islam when you follow the
teachings of the Quran when you follow
the teachings of the Prophet it Stan
tells you to respect your parents is one
of the biggest sins in Islam to
disrespect your parents to be good to
your neighbor to look after the poor and
the orphans and the needy so in Islam
part of believing in God is being good
to the creation you can't say that the
other way around you can't say about
those people humanists or whatever right
that they would say yeah yeah we should
be good to the creation whatever good to
the creation is because that's open for
discussion as well right you know they
what they think is good may not even be
good anyway right I mean maybe these
people now start saying you for nature
is good right you reach 70 years old
you're an old person put you down right
let's succeed it let's kill all people
because you know that it's not worth
them living who knows maybe in years to
come this is what people will be saying
yeah right and they will say oh that's
the good thing to do well we don't hold
that we don't agree that that's good
right so it all comes back to these
things who defines good right and the
whole issue of one's relationship with
Allah with the Creator is really at the
heart of this as well that's priority
number one and we'll be right back with
more on the Deen show
Heena he did you say that you're not
believing Jesus you have stepped outside
of this and I'm you can not be a Muslim
is attending our faith to believe in and
love Jesus Christ why is it then when it
comes to one of the most important
decisions in life we literally abuse
ourselves it's not that the main thing
we're looking for is to see what type of
money he has so that he can treat my
daughter like a princess that's not
about
back here on the Dean show and we're
trying to clear the confusion because
some people will say you know what I
feel like you know what I don't break
the law
I don't hurt nobody I give sometimes to
the poor I show up to work on time I
didn't murder nobody why would God
punish me and I believe in God once in a
while I'll say hey thanks God so that
person feels like hey God owes me
paradise now where I'm okay I'm set it's
all good I mean what do we say about
this well what we have to say is that
you can't decide for yourself what it is
that God wants from us you know you're
making up your own religion really then
what you're saying is that I'll define
the terms I'll define but it's not up to
you you don't decide whether you're
going to paradise paradise or not God
decides whether you're gonna go to
paradise and God has set down a set of
criterion this is the behavior of the
people who will go to paradise and this
is the behavior of the people who go to
Hellfire a blueprint is there everything
that's there God has that's why God has
sent his prophets that's why God has
sent us messengers and as we believe as
Muslims those prophets and messengers
have come with a consistent message the
basic message of those prophets is the
same and at the heart of it is first of
all you have to single out Allah for
worship and you have to worship Allah
not the way you want but the way that
God wants I give you a quick example
very quickly we've got time alright
let's go back to the example of the
parents you want to give your parents a
really nice present you know after years
they've done so much for you so you know
80 years old your parents are 80 years
old you take them down to a heavy metal
rock concert because that's what you
like I mean that's ridiculous you know
you're not you're not thanking your
parents the way they want to be Thanks
you're just doing something that you
happen to enjoy
that's not thanking them right the same
you know the same concept I'm not saying
goddess do it I'm not comparing God to
the birds but the concept isn't the same
is there no you have to thank God the
way he wants to be thanked not the way
that you just happen to choose
yeah explain this real quick we said
that God Almighty doesn't need our
worship if we all collaborated and did
it together it wouldn't diminish your ad
he is self-sufficient he is the true
king of kings the Lord of all creation
but then some on my ass then why do I
need to single him out or what I need to
pray what do we say well I mean that's
the way God created that's the way that
Allah Allah created you to do that if
you do it and you fulfill your created
purpose you'll go to paradise if you
don't you go to hell I mean it's it's
really very simple right if you show up
to work I don't understand do you
understand why people will understand
this if it comes to their daily chores
and activity the CEO he's got some rules
laid out at the company and people will
stick to those rules and understand it
look if I miss work social days for sure
I made a fire you said it you know the
point is if you look in your ordinary
everyday life right it's very simple it
makes a lot of sense you're absolutely
right if you don't turn up to work
sooner or later you'll get fired if you
know you can't go to a company and the
boss tells you do ABC and the use and
you do efg right the boss said I told
you ABC you did efg right you'll get
fired right it's the same thing why is
it surely why is it any different from
God God tells you do this and do this
and do this you'll get paradise and you
want to do something else if you want
paradise do what God wants you to do
know what you want to do is very simple
couple more points a couple more points
just tell us right now you are a known
figure and people look to you and you
have some confused you felt there and
you also have some people who now are
doing things that aren't in accordance
with Islam so for the not-yet Muslims
everything's making sense but now he's
heard 9/11 and they are saying we're
revisiting it and people are getting all
you know pumped up and then you have you
know the Christmas bomber and all these
things what do we got to say about this
does Islam have anything to do with this
you know well you said it so many times
it says don't kill women don't kill
children don't kill old people don't
attack the civilians this is what the
Prophet Muhammad told us that this is
this is not part of its lair
these are people's emotions these are
politics these are people who are gone
to extremes there are all sorts of
people who use religion to justify what
they want to do right and that's not an
exception
they don't say let me look and see what
God wants me to do no they say I have an
idea I want to do this let me find
something that I can use to justify it
from the religion that's not the way to
approach the religion the way to
approach the religion is holistically
let me understand what the religion
teaches and then implement it not I've
got some ideas how I want to take
revenge I've got some ideas how I want
to do that let me find a versatile
choripan that supports my that's not the
right way that's not you know that's how
you will just invent your own religion
and just find verses to and that's what
you find these people are not following
the teachings of Islam they see one
verse of the Quran that they forget
other verses they see one thing the
Prophet said but they forget the things
where the Prophet said don't kill women
don't kill children you know they just
clearly it's very clear they just but
you know in their own minds they just
put dismiss that or they rationalize it
or justify it because you know this I'm
sorry to say there is a sickness you
know they have a sickness in their heart
you know and whatever that sickness has
been caused by that's a whole different
discussion yes but it is not the
teachings of Islam this is not what the
scholars have taught this is not what
the prophet and his companions to it so
another thing you had mentioned before
and into the show if a Muslim drinks
cross said don't drink so if the Quran
says don't fornicate Muslim fornicating
Islam says don't kill women and children
don't do these horrific acts and now you
can't blame Islam if you study Islam
you'll see that Islam is free and clear
of most things now closing comments and
suggestions for those people who are
sincere they're getting fed up drama
from womb to the tomb depression anxiety
xanax but they like what we have to say
they like to call to acquire peace by
submitting to the owner peace the one
guy what do they have to do and what
advice do you give them the best thing
that you can
do in your life is bring the guidance
into your life but best thing you can do
is follow the Quran the best thing to do
is reconnect to Allah directly and you
do that by taking Islam as your way of
living taking Islam as your way of life
and it's very simple all you have to do
is say I bear witness that there is only
one God worthy of worship and I bear
witness that Muhammad is the Messenger
of God once you do that you start to
connect with your Creator by praying and
by fasting and giving charity and doing
the things that the Quran and the
Prophet told us to do it's very simple
it's very beautiful and I believe it is
the only way to true peace and happiness
in your life by accepting the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him you accept if
someone had attachment of Jesus you
accept him as a messenger Moses Abraham
all the preceding messengers of course I
mean in his family believe it all of
those messages but their message has
finished it's done it's done you know
like I gave the example if it's like you
know you have a school and the school
has a new new headmaster man and the new
headmaster or the new CEO of the company
writes new rules and said these are the
new rules and these are the new
procedures and this is the new way of
doing that someone can't come along and
say you know I'm gonna stick with the
old guy you know I preferred what he
said no you have the new CEO you have
the new headmaster you follow the new
rules and that's an Islam is the new
rules is the rules for us today and it
is in fact the last book of rules are
two of their judgment it's the final
Testament so for that you do that and
you get paradise by doing the good
worshipping God the way he wants you to
worship Him doing all the good deeds you
get His grace mercy and paradise working
people contact you the organization just
ten seconds time about wwii-era ie Rho
dou K ie Ronaldo you can find out about
us and what we think may God Almighty
reward you and I hope that we get to
Jenna Paradise together thank you
not much to add after that it's simple
you gotta want it and if you want
something you go out for it go out get
the guy to just raise your hands and
earnestly seek the guidance of the one
god distinguish god from his creation
everything that came into existence that
walked the earth had a zip code an airy
goat DNA that can't be God God is the
creator of man and one but he's not a
man or woman he created everything the
Sun in the universe everything this goes
with your nature so go ahead and ask
that one God to guide you and then be
ready to submit to all the good that
he's told you to do we'll see you next
time
inshallah God willing peace be unto you
[Music]
he created the universe to him anon the
heavens and the
that he is the first he's the owner
mercy eat them his messengers to all
these creatures on the great danger
worshipping other than Allah there is
none greater
the Creator
[Music]